this is how it felt when Italy's
lockdown lucinda little cecilia hasn't
seen her grandparents for two months the
reunion a delight for all of them
disparities i've gotten terribly posada
disparity they saw a couple Erickson in
would you not do is in all of Idi Amin a
solo videogame Attleboro non-lethal
states are no boys to lie to in Venice
where the emptiness of lockdown had felt
so very strange a round of applause for
Italy's health workers but this also
felt like a city exhaling in relief this
nation has suffered profoundly but now
it has a glimmer of how life should be
there are people in the parks even if
the signs have locked down are still all
around
Shyamalan took deliver to go Tiana B
only muscadine and it cousin quisha's
they've been swimming for the Tina
Hobley she not even so honored very
[ __ ] ago it's you so much dance it oh
come on Minerva see a bit of it on me
know what it's been on for Daria this is
Ferrari home to the world's most famous
racing cars and here amid all this
romance and heritage blood tests are
being done on staff to ensure they don't
have coronavirus Italy may have loosened
its shackles but it's not normal life
the main thing which differentiates you
mentioned the serological tests which
are completely voluntary but we've had
95 percent of the workforce who were
able to do them at the moment have taken
part and not only we're doing they're
from our staff where we were
subsequently doing both of their
families and also for our supplies we've
come into the into the factories
in Rome you can now go out to buy a
Nespresso coffee it comes from a barista
in a mask and you have to take it away
but there is an echo here of the life we
used to know
Adam Parsons Sky News